whenever we can we like to tie in
something that's going on now to the
classic interview that we do on Fridays
and the Brett Kavanaugh hearings are a
really really good tie in to this week's
classic interview which was done in 2015
with almost Camille who exposed child
sex abuse at a Catholic school and of
course Cavanaugh went to Catholic High
School this sort of persona as a choir
almost literally as a choir boy who
would never drink or do anything other
than playing basketball having my beers
going a summer camp you know whatever it
was that he was talking about a lot of
crazy things go on at Catholic school
and that's why we're going to go back to
my interview from December of 2015 with
almost Camille child sex abuse scandal
at Catholic school this week's classic
interview I'm joined today by almost
Camille playwright screenwriter
investigative reporter his 2012 cover
story in The New York Times Magazine
brought the Horace Mann scandal to light
he graduated from Horace Mann School in
1982 almost it's so great to talk to you
let's start at the beginning
what is the Horace Mann School for
people who aren't familiar with it sure
Horace Mann sort of plays on a big stage
in American educational history it's
parentally perennial II voted one of the
top 10 schools in the country by Forbes
it's an elite private school in the
Riverdale section of the Bronx
and really the one percent I've always
sent their kids to hm and today it's
more like the 1% of the 1% and I was
lucky enough to get a scholarship there
when I was a sophomore I was a good
baseball player and I was recruited to
go there so at the time they had a lot
of middle class kids there as well and
in the Boston area is probably like the
Milton school or something like that
snow and you graduated in 1982 and you
broke this story in a New York Times
article about just the rampant sexual
abuse in 2012 how did you decide on the
timing of that
that's right act so it was a slow
process essentially we had known
that there were I wouldn't say abusers
but at the time in me in the language of
a 15 year old teachers acting strange or
stay away from this one stay away from
that one those kind of whispers and both
boys and girls at the school that the
school went co-ed in 75 we would talk
pretty openly about which teachers to
avoid then about 10 years later after I
graduated I went camping with there are
five of us and we went camping and one
night a guy that I call Andrew in the
book told us that he had been abused by
a very popular football coach named Mark
Wright and what happened after that was
we went around the campfire telling
different stories about drinking with
teachers about rumors a couple of cover
stories came out that night and then we
went on with our lives and about it was
literally 20 years later the Sandusky
trial hit and he was everywhere Penn
State and I called Andrew and I asked
him how he was doing and he said I'm not
doing too well I wish somebody would
write about it and that as you suggest
ultimately became prep school predators
which was the cover story of The Times
magazine in June of 2012 and what's your
understanding now of how many people
were well I guess the two sides to the
question how many teachers and staff
were abusing students and also how many
students were abused at the time that we
published in the that I published a
piece in The Times
we had accused credibly three teachers
of abuse what happened in the wake of
the article was really just a tsunami of
credible accusations and now sadly we're
up to 22 abusers at Horace Mann not
victims victims were probably a 32 have
come forward entered into a very
difficult mediation process with the
school but we know there's many more out
there but that's why we were we wrote
great as the truth it was really the the
number you know to date it's though it's
the largest recorded concentrate
of sexual abusers in one institution in
American educational history and we knew
it was bad we didn't know it was quite
this bad it was sort of uh you know
Catholic school bad as somebody said
Catholic Church bad and we know about
sexual abuse being drastically
underreported in part often there's like
a power dynamic sort of situation that
prevents victims from from feeling
comfortable reporting it sometimes it's
an issue of shame what's your sense of
why at Horace Mann school there were not
reports about what was going on well at
the time I thought that there weren't
reports we now know that several people
actually did come forward and there's a
whole range I mean the abuse at Horace
Mann was so widespread that there's a
large spectrum of ways to answer that
that specific question some people like
many victims just sort of sealed it away
and said I don't want to ever talk about
this many labored under the impression
for decades that they were the only one
that had happened to some teachers and
administrators covered it up others
didn't know so the power dynamic not
just at Horace Mann other places too is
really what helps seal in the silence so
for instance if a kid is abused boy or
girl one of the acts that the teacher
that the adult does is they they make
the child complicit in the act right
right so they'll think that it's it's
Mutual and you know what do you have a
40 year old in a fifteen year old it's
not mutual it's a power dynamic there so
they start silence silencing themselves
then many years later if they actually
come forward oftentimes they're not
believed and so they learn to stuff it
even more and the the legal system quite
frankly New York New York is where
Horace Mann is has an unbelievably
strict statute of limitations law so a
child has only until a person who's been
abused has only until the age of 23 to
come forward in both civil
criminal cases and we know that most
people if they ever talk about it only
do so when they're in their 40s or 50s
42 being the average and as you talked
about there's this sort of mediation
process that has been going on there
have been some settlements offered by
the school some people have accepted
settlements not everybody has do you
have any sense as to the size of some of
these individual settlements that were
reached
well because Horace Mann didn't really
most of the issue the cases of abuse
were well past the age of 23 right
Horace Mann took a very hard ball
position and as I said 32 people came
forward and they took the position that
we don't owe you anything so whatever
you get is gonna be out of the goodness
of our own hearts and many of these
people you have to remember this is some
among some of the wealthiest people on
the planet who sit on Horace Mann's
board billionaire hedge fund folks and
real estate people
so if victims legal counsel was asking
for a million dollars two million
dollars Horace Mann would counter with
something along the lines of five or ten
thousand dollars Wow and for some people
they understood it was a negotiation
others started talking about Reid being
reach Rama ties by that hardball
position and certainly didn't lead to
healing and is that I mean I know you've
said you've had feelings of guilt for
sort of opening this Pandora's box with
the 2012 New York Times article does
this retraumatization that you're
talking about play a role in why you've
had feelings of guilt or talk about that
a little bit sure you know at the time
when those of us who were not abusive or
sort of inner circle watching and
hearing what was coming back from the
mediation process I started to question
what good it was all doing and I think
I've since changed but I had moments of
doubt and also moments of doubt of just
all of them the the sort of poison
coming out and you know I started to
really understand why people keep silent
for so long it was just so horrible was
coming out and really why you know why I
wrote great is the truth is really
because not not what happened in the
past right we can't really fix that but
what how Haris man its current
administration reacted in the present
there's a way most victims don't come
forward looking for money they don't
really have the strength to do so many
of them they're looking usually for two
things one for somebody to acknowledge
that what happened to them actually
happened to them and two from somebody
from the institution to actually
apologize so that didn't it happened in
a very Lord up way in the Horace Mann
case and although some people I don't
want to speak for everybody some people
are pleased that they've been able to
move on with their lives many many many
of the victims and many of us watching
from the outer circle are saying Horace
we thought our school was better than
that and the this is the name of the
book raid is the truth is the motto of
the school so that just sort of added
insult to injury last thing I want to
touch on in the limited time we have
left
what's your sense of how much school
administrators knew at the time of what
was going on my sense is that they knew
not all of them but they knew there were
as new headmasters came aboard they were
told certainly some of the board members
knew certainly some of the teachers knew
new term that because students had
either come to them or their their kids
had told them in some cases that
teachers actually went to administrators
so I definitely assume that everybody
knew all the teachers knew at the
beginning I've stuffand a little but
many adults who were there at the time
and remember the abuse happened from
1962 into the late 90s 96 being the
latest that we know of so that's an
extraordinary long period for people to
know about all this abuse going on and
it's a tiny campus there's you know 600
people
hardest man at any given time so people
definitely knew I'll remind everybody
the book is great is the truth secrecy
scandal and the quest for justice at the
Horace Mann School we've been speaking
with the book's author almost Camille
thanks so much for being here and
telling us the story I really appreciate
it David